your brain is constantly pinging noise
you want to do anything you can just to
turn it off it's saying yesterday
yesterday yes you may tomorrow tomorrow
yesterday yesterday work where we're
girlfriend girlfriend girlfriend and all
this noise is just pinging all day long
you take ketamine it's almost like
taking your consciousness out of that
completely all this noise is gone and
there's just complete and utter
stillness ketamine is a clinical
anesthetic that's probably better known
as the club drug Special K taken at high
doses it can send users into a k-hole an
out-of-body experience that's been
described as the kind of mental
paralysis but take the right dose under
the right conditions and it could be a
lifesaver for patients with treatment
resistant depression I know people who
have been on the brink of suicide and
done it and it's 180 changed their lives
where next day they were like I'm better
to treat his depression Shawn Spencer
visits the ketamine clinics of Los
Angeles the first time I was in this
chair I was pretty nervous certainly
didn't know what to expect he's about to
get his eighth IV infusion I don't think
anybody should be afraid of it you know
you're not you're not getting handed
pills in a club by somebody you're going
to a professional and you're in a space
that's safe ketamine is the most
important breakthrough in the treatment
of depression in decades dr. Stephen
Mandel runs the clinic we give them a
very gradual infusion over 50 minutes on
the first infusion 55 minutes on
subsequent infusions despite its
reputation as a party drug ketamine is
primarily a cheap and effective
painkiller that's used all around the
world now more and more it's being
administered off-label
to treat severe cases of depression the
other antidepressants take weeks to
months to have an effect
ketamine kicks in within hours to at the
most a couple of days are you getting
enough medicine yeah most
antidepressants change levels of
serotonin neurotransmitters but ketamine
might alter glutamate receptors instead
well that may be the key distinction
that doctors still aren't exactly sure
how the treatment works we don't know
how any of these medications work on the
brain we know as much about ketamine as
we do about
any of the others we do know that
ketamine tends to cause new growth in
the brain it literally enhances
neuroplasticity pretty quickly I mean
within five minutes you're moving you're
blasting off when you get to the deepest
part of it you feel ultimate peace from
the outside
Spencer seems to have it all in 2013 he
co-founded a successful startup in LA
silicon beach tech community but that's
also around the time he suffered his
first major panic attack seems like
somebody looking at my life from the
outside would think like was that guy
have to be depressed about but it's it
doesn't work like that you have to look
at your brain is almost like a like an
operating system and if that system
crashes it doesn't matter if you have
all the comforts of life here you're
still miserable and he's not alone
according to a 2015 study entrepreneurs
are twice as likely to suffer from
depression these people really are
playing a very high-risk game he should
know most of dr. Mandela's patients come
from the silicon beach tech community
you know when somebody has a job they
may not consider the job part of who
they are professionals entrepreneurs
creative types or their job if you're
admitting to maybe having anxiety or
being depressed you're giving the
impression that you're weak so Spencer
tried prescription meds but up to a
third of patients don't respond to
traditional antidepressants I felt like
a zombie I just thought if this is gonna
be the rest of my life like I'm out then
he heard about the ketamine infusions I
got to a point where I just felt like I
was at the end of my rope and I didn't
have and I really have any other options
it works on people that nothing else has
worked on to help them with their
depression but not all physicians are
sold on the treatment the main critique
is that it's been rolled out into
clinical usage too soon and there's so
much about the drug that we don't know
in terms of how to use it who responds
to it what the long-term consequences of
taking the drug might be
and the treatment still isn't
fda-approved which means many insurance
carriers won't cover the cost and then
there's the potential for long term
dependency on a treatment that still
isn't fully understood but for Spencer
it's worth the risk
I hope in the future that it's more
accessible to more people because I know
a lot of people who are a lot worse off
than I've ever been and they could use
it even more
[Music]